-Oh, you know what
I wanted to mention here?
Because there's a connection
between "Reservoir Dogs"
and "The Golden Girls,"
involving you.
-Sorta kinda.
I don't know if people
knew about this.
What is the connection?
-Okay, the connection was,
before I did "Reservoir Dogs,"
I had a very unsuccessful
acting career.
However, one of the few jobs
I did get --
Is this the camera?
This is the camera.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, one of the few jobs
I did get --
[ Laughter ]
-I love that Quentin Tarantino
just directed our show.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
That's the best thing
that ever happened to us!
-Camera two!
-This is fantastic!
This is best thing
to ever happen to us!
So happy.
Oh, my God.
That is awesome.
-Okay, slow move in.
[ Laughter ]
Slow, I mean, really like --
-Slow move in, yeah, come on.
-Like, get dramatic.
-Yeah, that's -- all right.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
What were we talking about?
Oh, yeah.
-"Golden Girls."
-Okay, yeah, okay.
So, I had a very unsuccessful
acting career.
[ Laughter ]
However, one of the jobs
I did get, and not because
I did a wonderful audition,
but simply because they sent
my picture in, and they said,
"He's got it,"
was for an Elvis impersonator
on "The Golden Girls."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, were you into Elvis
at the time?
-Oh, yeah! Oh, I was, like --
Well, that's why it worked.
Because I walked around
dressed like Elvis in the '80s.
I wore a pompadour all the time.
-Really?
-I actually went to a rockabilly
place to get my hair cut.
-Yes!
-Like, the people that cut
the Stray Cats' hair...
-Brian Setzer.
-Yeah, and the people that cut
The Blasters' hair,
they cut my [bleep] hair.
Or, they cut my hair.
Sorry.
-It's all right, we got you.
[ Laughter ]
We can bleep you out,
no worries.
Yeah, no problem.
-Yeah.
So I literally got from, like,
rockabilly professionals,
I got my hair done that way.
And the black shoe polish
going on,
and I wore houndstooth coats
and dressed like
a hillbilly cat.
-Wow.
-And, um --
And so I did this
"Golden Girls."
And it's like Sophia's wedding
is what it was.
And the thing is,
we were like a --
We have a chorus at the end.
It became a two-part
"Golden Girls."
So I got paid residuals
for both parts.
All right?
And it was so popular,
they put it on
a "Best of 'The Golden Girls,'"
and I got residuals
every time that showed.
So I got paid maybe --
I don't know --
$650 for the episode.
-Yeah.
-But by the time the residuals
were over, three years later,
I made like $3,000.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-And that kept me going
during our preproduction time
trying to get
"Reservoir Dogs" going.
-So thank "Golden Girls"
for "Reservoir Dogs."
I mean, that's what I'm saying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a shame
we don't have the clip,
because I would love to show --
Oh, wait, we do have it.
-Oh!
-Here's Quentin Tarantino
as an Elvis impersonator
on "The Golden Girls."
Check this out.
-♪ I want you ♪
♪ I love you ♪
♪ With all my heart ♪
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got a big laugh.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and by the way,
you will notice,
I'm not like the Vegas guy
in the long -- in the jumpsuit.
-That's too obvious.
-I'm the Sun Records Elvis.
I am absolutely
the Sun Record --
And I'm totally doing my --
♪ Got a lot of living to do ♪
♪ Got a lot of
loving to do, oh, baby ♪
♪ Baby ♪
Yeah, I'm singing my own song,
regardless of
what they're singing.
-I love that.
By the way,
happy birthday, Elvis.
Today is his birthday.
-Happy birthday, Elvis!
-Today is his birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was showing this DVD earlier,
and I've never seen
a box like this.
I almost -- for a second, I
thought it was an eight-track.
-Yeah, it does look --
-Right?
-Yeah, I --
Wow, I didn't even --
Until you put it on, I didn't
realize we have a black thing.
-Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
-A black-ray.
-You should be --
-You should have
the soundtrack on eight-track.
-I agree.
-The soundtrack is crusher,
by the way.
-Thank you very much.
-They're always great.
You -- I don't know how you --
How do you pick these songs
for your movies?
'Cause they're awesome,
and I almost don't --
I go, "Oh, I love that song,"
or, "I've never
heard that song."
-Well, you know, part of
the thing is, it's like,
when I'm coming up
with a film --
See, I have -- I'm lucky.
Where it's like -- I have
a whole vinyl room in my house.
Where it's like, it's all done
up like a used-record store.
-Wow.
-And all broken down
into categories and everything
so you can
thumb through everything.
And I've got, like,
movie posters
that have to do with movies
on the wall.
I have my platinum records
up there.
Just saying.
-No big deal.
-Just sayin', just sayin'.
-Yeah, me too.
-But part of
the thing is, though,
when I'm thinking about
a new movie,
I go through
my record collection,
and I start playing music that
could be right for the film.
And then,
if I find enough of it,
that actually makes me
move to the next step,
the next part of the process.
All right, so, like,
it's like, uh --
Like something in the case
of something like
"Django Unchained,"
I'm thinking about
spaghetti Western music.
And so I'm playing my spaghetti
Western soundtracks.
And when I finally
find enough of them
that actually
sound interesting --
And then I'm playing
my '70s soul soundtracks
because that needs --
for something like
"Django Unchained," that needs
to fit itself into there.
So when I find a couple of them,
I go, "Hey!
I might have a movie here.
This could be interesting."
Same thing with "Jackie Brown."
I went, like, just deep diving
into '70s soul music
and exploitation soundtracks,
like women-prison movie
soundtracks and everything.
And then,
by putting those together,
it's like, "Oh, hey,
I think I could have a movie."
So it's like --
It's not what the movie's about,
but it's sort of the kind of
the walls of
the gingerbread house...
-Yeah.
-...to some degree or another.
-Is the movie written
by the time you're picking
these songs or --
-No, that's usually, like,
me thinking about doing it.
All right?
Like, okay, like,
"Oh, this might be
the next thing
I sit down and write."
So maybe I've written,
like, the first scene.
-Yeah.
-I've done it enough
for it to be more than an idea.
-Yeah.
-But I haven't committed 100% to
"This is what I'm doing next."
And so I've committed enough
to writing, like,
maybe the first scene or, like,
a fragment of a sequence,
or some dialogue back and forth
between a character.
And then I go into the deep dive
to figure out the --
figure out the movie sonically.
-Well, you've set the bar
for soundtracks
and for films, in general.
We love you, buddy.
-Thank you so much, Jimmy.
Appreciate it.
That is Quentin Tarantino.
-My first time here!
-"Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood."
First time on the show!